what you know what it's so funny because
what it's not funny but when you when I
found when I knew that you were coming
here I was a little nervous because it
just didn't know how this was gonna go
and I really it was needed for me this
is a wake-up call because I feel and I
apologize to kalila because I've just
been in a real I've never been this away
before I'm in the press if that was me
about 18 months ago really yeah yeah and
all these things that you're saying to
me is ringing complete true to me and I
know what I need to be doing yeah and if
you don't do it doesn't mean anything
it's like you go [ __ ] said that walks
without walks what the works you try to
make everything aged needs to be what
was it saying again
let me say faith without works is dead
right is what I wanted to say right
right another point to carry home with
you is that you know you don't have
people expect a gift when sobriety is
the gift right you the conversation we
had yesterday was I need you know a bad
food nicotine indulgent life's that all
of this because I'm sober now you stop
talking like that no point in my house
like that yeah I know what I was doing
pulling why you look so guilty you
looked at me like really guilty and I'm
like I know I've said it to my wife I
know I know I tried to pull something
yesterday we're sure because of the fact
that I'll just tell you I quit smoking
two years ago a year and a half ago
right but I've been vaping okay okay and
eating very indulgently okay fried foods
and I have high blood pressure I have
I've strokes in my family you know so I
can't move my neck it hurts so bad
because of my high blood pressure every
time my neck hurts like we get she has
what do they call it
stroke out now stroke out yes change
your lifestyle move a burn a calorie
it's like he's attached to his video
game for 16 hours a day
so I play 16 hours of video games right
yeah and I've a bit like a crazy person
right and I'm trying to not to vape
because of the fact that um my neck is
hurting
yeah and I'm in a situation where I need
to get out of this rut also on top of it
I have great things happening because of
this podcast I have great things
happening in my career right and you
know I'm just getting work you know and
everything and and yet I'm miserable so
you know and I and III made admit to
turn away okay you can't be vulnerable
he's king white and I cannot was pretty
look I go like I'm a Scottish Protestant
he's white to me
he's country why did I am dude I'm like
man that is a white guy beyond even
that's why yeah when I'm being
vulnerable I can't have pure white get
it man look away [ __ ] nut all right and
I have to treat them that way because of
the fact that I oz of history that's
right right the history of what you
folks have done all right well to be
fair right